نظام البشير اصبحوا خارج سجن كوبر الذي
يعد من اكبر واقدم سجون العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم لكن ماذا عن الرئيس السابق عمر
البشير سؤال تصدر المشهد السوداني بعدما
كشف الوزير السابق احمد الهارون وهو احد
ابرز رموز نظام البشير عن هربه وهروب
قيادات اخرى تابعه للنظام السابق من سجن
كوبر
بخروج كل النزلاء يوم الاحد 23 ابريل 2023
من السجن عنوه
حتى خلعت نارا منه زلائه وصيانه فيما عدا
قله لا تتجاوز العشره من قاده وضباط
وافراد وبناء على طلب القوه المتبقيه من
قوه السجون تحركنا لموقع اخر خارجي تحت
حراسه محدوده لا تتعدى الثلاثه من تلك
القوه
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع كلاهما
تبادل الاتهامات حول هذه القصه تحديدا
الجيش اكد بان البشير وبعض قيادات حزبه
كانوا ولا يزالون محتجزين في مستشفى علياء
العسكري قبل اندلاع الاشتباكات لكن قوات
الدعم السريع اتهمت قيادات مواليه للبشير
بالامر وبالتامر وفق ما قاله المستشار
السياسي لقائد قوات دعم السريع يوسف عزت
للعربيه العناصر الاسلاميه داخل الجيش انا
لا اتهم كل الجيش الجيش ليس كله حركه
اسلاميه هنالك ضباط شرفاء ولكن هنالك جهات
داخل الاستخبارات العسكريه هنالك جهات
ضباط اسلاميين ساهموا في اطلاق صراحه هذه
المجموعه
سجن كوبر مشاهدينا الذي سلطت عليه الاضواء
امتدت الاشتباكات اليه وتعرض لقصف مدفعي
من مساهم بهرب مئات السجناء منهم سجناء
محكوم عليهم بالاعدام
هذا السجن سجن كوبر هو السجن المركزي في
البلاد ويقع في مدينه بحري بالقرب من
النيل الازرق بالعاصمه الخرطوم تبلغ مساحه
السجن حوالي خمسه الاف متر مربع وتم
تصميمه على شكل هندسي يحاكي سجون بريطانيا
بعدما تولى مهام اداره هذا السجن الجنرال
الانجليزي كوبر خلال فتره الاحتلال ويضم
السجن 14 قسما من بين هذه الاقسام قسم
مخصص للمدانين باحكام الاعدام وقسم
للمعتقلين السياسيين وبطبيعه الحال قسم من
المحكوم عليهم باحكام طويله وقصيره يبعد
السجن مشاهدينا عن المستشفى العسكري نحو
عشره كيلومترات اي حوالي 17 دقيقه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات